we're going to go back to Imran Khan who
is at the airport in Doha and Imran can
you just explain what is happening there
is the plane actually landed or is it
about to in the next minute or so
well I've just been informed that the
flight monitoring website flight tracker
has the plane circling and it looks
likely that it's going to land fairly
soon I'll just show you where uh it's
going to land in it will land on that
Runway over there which direction is
coming in from is actually slightly
unclear to me right now but it will taxi
to where near where that white plane is
once it's there
the freed prisoners will disembark and
they'll Wander over to walk over rather
to the terminal building where they'll
be met by the American delegation from
the U.S embassy here in Doha and also
the state department now we think that
they are going to be fairly quickly
moved to the United States where they
move from here or whether they move from
Hamad International Airport just a few
kilometers down the road is unclear but
they will go to the US they'll be given
a medical evaluation there and then
they'll be given a security debriefing
once that has actually happened
um the Iranians side will also start to
talk about what happened with their guys
now two of their guys have actually
already arrived haven't had that
independently confirmed but that's what
we're hearing three of them uh are left
two of those are actually U.S citizens
they'll stay in America and one will
move to a third party now I'm just going
to get out the way now because I am
hearing it's landed so stay with us
um hopefully we will see I can see some
lights in the far off distance
whether that's the plane or not there it
is there is the plane over there that's
the Qatar Airways A320 that's the A320
that took over I'm presuming that's the
plane I can't confirm but that looks
like the plane it looks like it has
landed we knew it was an A320 from there
about Airport
as you can see it's coming in now
Imran obviously it has a big moment for
the catteries yeah just on that
obviously Qatar didn't just Supply a
plane and a runway for it to land on can
you explain the role of Qatar in this
negotiation
well Carter did the epitome of
protectively Shuffle diplomacy they went
to Tehran they went to Washington uh
they negotiated this deal then in the
last few months uh both delegations from
around America came to Doha they stayed
in a hotel uh different hotels the two
parties never met face to face it was
the cartoons that went between them
negotiating this deal very intense
negotiations we're hearing about eight
rounds of negotiations took place so
that was the bare bones of the deal what
we don't know is what was actually
talked about Lewis what the sticking
points were but clearly one of the
sticking points was this transfer of six
billion dollars we are hearing that once
that had been agreed upon the deal was
over the line now you can see uh the
gangway going up to the plane there
the it's likely that they're going to
come out quite quickly now we're hearing
that three of the Iranians Americans
rather will come down that gangway
they're the ones that were allowed to
film two of the American citizens want
their identity uh uh not to be revealed
that's perhaps the request of the
families but this like I say very big
moment for the category is a very big
moment for the Iranians as well indeed
stop talking now so you can see what's
happening the door's about to open
foreign
so that's it the final few moments this
was two years in negotiation ended with
a two hour flight
so we're waiting for that door to open
like I say it has been choreographed the
three people that will come out first
will include uh the 51 year old business
fancy mcnamazi he had a huge Twitter
social media campaign calling for his
release uh
so he's actually very public or with it
we're unlikely to hear from them though
they're going to be Spirited Away uh
very quickly by the U.S representatives
that are waiting on the tarmac for them
Imran this is obviously a huge moment
for those people awaiting to disembark
can you just give us a sense of what the
feeling is like there what is the mood
there on the runway
the mood on the runway has changed
significantly there's a visible sense of
actual relief
um the U.S ambassador he stood in
between the two categories he's wearing
the dark blue suit he's waiting there uh
he'll just shake their hands he arrived
about an hour ago
um the U.S have their delegation have
been here for most of the day but the
closer we were getting to this plane
landing uh the more I want to say kind
of nervous excitement you could see in
their faces but it's actually really
interesting the Iranians were here
earlier now like I say the Iranians and
the Americans never met face to face but
at one point they were in the same
terminal building the doors are now open
let's see who comes out first
they're just doing their final checks
US ambassador there waiting
and it looks like
from where I can see they're about to
come out
one final check and we've all taken
international flights before it's never
easy getting off the plane is it no it
certainly these guys must be desperate
to get back onto get off that plane
yeah get off that plane and be back in
the hands of their American counterparts
Imran you were telling us a little bit
about the official delegation that is
due to meet them uh there when they step
off the plane what about their families
are there any family members or friends
that have also made it to Doha
no
I haven't seen here they are they're
coming off
was he uh he's uh in the blue suit in
front uh and then I think it's the 68
year old professor and then uh a third
man that's we're walking down these are
the three people that we are allowed to
film the other two uh requested uh to be
anonymous I think my cameraman is very
aware of that so we may have to cut away
if they walk down as well but there's a
big hug look at that a big hug from the
American ambassador there clearly the
relieved of this two-year deal a
two-year deal that was uh negotiated and
like I say two-year deal but it was only
a two-hour flight in the end handshakes
all round
can you just tell us a little bit more
about the length of time that they these
men had been held uh in Iranian jails
it's been for Sam mcnamaze who's the one
that's actually been very very public
about this Middle East uh three uh years
for him uh in Evan prison in uh Iran so
that's going to be uh I have a big
effect on his character but it's all
smiles right now you can see smiles and
handshakes and hugs
um from the U.S delegation that the
three uh prisoners all actually hugging
each other as well they must be so
relieved uh that they're out on the
tarmac
um
but yes uh they were arrested on a
suspicion of spying something they've
always known something that the US has
always denied and then the Iranians were
arrested actually in the America in
America as well they were arrested for
sanctions busting or for working for the
uh Iranian government so there's a lot
of accusations flying around none of
them have been proven
um uh at least on the Iranian side and
so this is a like I said a big moment
they're now walking in like I say years
in prison years in prison and now
they're free and they are walking into
that terminal building you can just
imagine how they feel right
it must be a remarkable sense of relief
and I can see the official
absolutely and I can see the official
U.S photographer there he's taking their
pictures for the U.S record uh they're
moving very slowly it's only a two-hour
flight but it's clear that there's a lot
of emotions going on like I say when
they go into that building uh they'll be
given uh their plans it's not likely
that they're going to stay in Doha for
that long the Americans will want to get
them out and get them on U.S soil where
like I said that we're given a health
evaluation and a security keep briefing
it's worth mentioning at this point that
president raisi was actually asked about
the health of the prisoners uh in the
last 24 hours he said they've been
treated very very well that they're in
good spirits they're in good health and
it looks I mean they certainly look uh
like they're in good spirits and in good
health very difficult to tell from here
but the Americans will want to get them
on U.S soil as soon as possible and so
they're now walking in to the building
I'm gonna have to cut away from this
shop the U.S state Department have asked
us not to show the two people whose
identities they've asked to remain
silent but there you have it there is
the Qatar Airways A320 flew in from
meribad airport uh it's about a two hour
flight landed and uh the pro they freed
prisoners are now inside the terminal
where their next plans are being forged
and this is all down to intense
negotiations for the catteries this is a
tremendous success and it was literal
shuttle diplomacy the two sides never
met catteries had to go from hotel to
hotel and they did it eight rounds of
talks at least over two years and this
is the end result
Imran does this signal the end of the
entire process two years of talks
two-hour flight is this the official end
of it now
it's the official end of the prisoner
Exchange
is it the end of negotiations it really
depends on who you speak to uh some
people throughout the day have been
telling us that they hope that this is
the group The Blueprint the road map for
future indirect negotiations the
Americans slightly less a slightly more
pessimistic suggesting that actually
this is a silo deal it was a one-off
deal uh that isn't going to be repeated
any time soon and certainly won't lead
to the two sides getting around a table
and hammering out a deal particularly on
Iran's nuclear energy program however
having said that the catteries have
proved that they can do this kind of
diplomacy they've done it very well
they've done it in the past before with
Lebanon with Sudan with various other uh
conflicts have been going on in various
parts of the world they've proved
themselves to be effective mediators uh
so the question it's a very big question
is this a reproachment between the U.S
and Iran but the obvious answer I have
to say is not really the Americans are
insisting this was a silo deal it was a
one-off but in direct negotiations
that's something entirely different that
may well be on the card perhaps not in
the immediate future but certainly on
the cards at some point indeed well
thank you so much Imran for talking us
through all of that that is Imran Khan
for us at the airport in Doha